サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチットパリヨダパナン エタングブッダナササナン
では よろしくお願いします
それから 今日のテーマについて語りたいと思います
テーマはなぜブッダを念じると幸福になるのか？というね
ちょっと色合いの合わせが良くないみたいですけどね
各者の徳を学ぶ意味 で
ということで まあテーマのこのテーマのね
あの 何と言いますかね
考えはね まあこれってハッキリしたね
ブッダを念じなさいと言われればね
宗教でしょうということになるんですね
それはどんどん説明して進めたいと思いますけど
基本的に宗教っていうのはね
マインドコントロールというかね
洗脳する方法なんですね
何か妄想概念先に作って
それを信じなさいと言って
それからとことんあらゆる関係ないデータを解釈解釈して納得させるんですね
そうすると心がどんどん洗脳して
自分で考えることをできなくなるんですね
それで決まられたパターンで考えるようになるんですね
どんな宗教にしても同じことになるんです
仏教はもうそれはもう宗教と大反対で
もう智慧の教えですから
心を開発しなくちゃいけないんですね
智慧を開発しなくちゃいけないんですね
人格を向上しなくちゃいけないんですよ
情けない人間になるものではないんですね
何か変な神秘体験を得ることでもないんです
超越した体験は仏教では確実にありますよ
神秘体験ではないんです
超越した体験 だから そういう経験がある人々にとっては
それは神秘体験ではないんです
ごく普通にもう身につく能力になります
で それも得るものではなくね
自分が修行して獲得する力なんですね
それからこの この病気になったら皆様薬を飲みますね
あるいはウイルスに感染しないようにワクチンとかね
注射したりしますね なんか微妙に似てるんですよ
どうしようもないんです
ワクチンはウイルスと似ているんです
でもウイルスじゃないんです
ウイルス注射したら死にますからね
で あのヘビに噛まれたらね
毒 猛毒ですね 解毒剤あるんですね
あれは毒で作るんです
ヘビが持っている毒をね
そこはタンパク質ですけど
そこをまず取って そこから薬を作るんです
あの このヘビの毒に対する解毒剤はね
アンチヴェノムって英語で言いますけどね
アンチヴェノムという薬は全部そのそのヘビの毒から作るんです
なんか世の中そうなってるみたいですね
なんでそういうことを言ったのかというと
この洗脳されている我々を洗脳から解放
解放して自由になるためのプロセスもなんとなく似ているんです
だからこういう九徳念じなさいと言ったところで
あのロードスプレーヤーというカトリック教のね
神様の祈りと同じものではないかと
似ているんじゃというふうに思うかも
なんか形式的に似てるみたいだけど
アンチヴェノムという注射する薬と毒が似てないんですよ
結局は似ていて似てないんです
ヘビに噛まれた人にあれ薬注射したら毒がなくなるんですね
でも毒から作ったんです
同じ毒から だから物質世界もそうなってます
だから精神の場合も結局そうなるんですよ
だからそこら辺にはこのなんか表面的に似てるんだけど
本当は全く正反対 違うものであると理解してほしいんです
ヘビの毒と解毒剤 同じ毒から作るんだけど
機能は正反対です だから何かを念じるということは
なんか宗教っぽいです
明らかに しかし 知恵を開発するために
人格向上するために この邪魔になっているのは洗脳なんですね
迷信 我々たくさん迷信を持っているんですね
だから自由にならないんです
怖くて 迷信やということでね
こんな捨てることもできないんです
いくらなんでもということで
まあまあもう一応気をつけましょうということで
どんな宗教に対してもすごい気をつけて
もう丁寧に扱ったりもする
あれは怖いんだからなんですね
まあ間違っているものはドカンと間違っていると言っちゃってもね
まあ別にどうってことないんだけど
怖いんですよ どこかで
そういうことであるプログラムを実践して
私たちは心を自由にするということにしなくちゃいけないんです
これで今回のレイアウトでタイトルは下に来るんですね
なんか逆さまになってます
人生を創造するメカニズム
思考が人生を構成します
あのポイント このまま説明はいりません
そのまま理解してください
理解すると言ったってもできないかも
このまま事実です どうしようもないです
理解するかしないか もう知らない
私たちの人生を 私たち人間だけじゃないんです
どんな生命のも その生涯を構成するのは
作り作るのは思考なんです
人の幸不幸は思考次第です
神または得体を知らない力がないんです
結構断言的に言います
外から私たちをいじっている
操っている力がないんです
ないと言っても 皆様も日本人だから
日本文化を持ってるんだから
やっぱりないと言いたくない
ないんですね やっぱりご先祖様やら神社の神様やらね
あらゆる八百万の神様たちも助けてくれているんではないかな
とかね 思ったりする あれはないんです
そう気分次第で思ってるだけ
客観的に調べると出てこない
だから仏教はすごい精密だから
もう科学者よりも精密にそういうものを調べてあります
だからあの人のおかげでっていうのは
社会的に言ってください
両親のおかげでとかね
師匠の先生のおかげで
今私はここでこういますよとかね
そういうふうに協力はありますよ
でもそれも証拠はあるんですね
親のおかげで自分がしっかりした人間になりましたと
で 環境があまりもよくよくいい環境に育てられたんだから
まあ健康になりましたと
いう場合は構いません
しかし この湧き水に素晴らしい霊が憑いてるんだから
この湧き水から私は水を飲んでるんだから病気にならないと言ったら
それは嘘です 綺麗な水を長く長い間飲んでくると
結構体が健康になるんです
薬はまずいらないんです
薬の代わりに体を健康状態で保ちたければ水でいいんです
しかし それが汚れてないきれいな水でなければ
それでまあ私たちはミネラルウォーターとかいろいろ水を買って飲んでますけど
まあどうかなと思います
結局は富士山のなんか雪解け水かもしれませんし
元では本当にいい水かもしれませんだけど
あれは工場の中でね いろんな機械通して
もうプラスチックの瓶に入ったら
まあかなり汚れてますよ
だから私はこの湧き水
この柿 柿川なんとかっていうところとかね
あの元のところに行ったら
びっくりするほど水がね
上がってきてね これこそ宝物
財産でしょうとね 人間の
と思ったんだけど そこで汲んで水を飲むと
やっぱり違うんですね
あれはもう体の中にずっと入っちゃうんで
なんか水を飲んだって重みもないんです
すぐ細胞の中に入っちゃうんですね
だから細胞はかなりかなりもう洗うんですよ
だから全細胞は綺麗に洗って毒を出しちゃえばもう健康なんです
でもまあそこまで我々は恵まれてないんだからどうしようもないんだけど
だからって日本の水は悪いわけじゃないんだからね
とことんたくさん水飲んでください
私に関係ない話をしてもね
だから この自分の家のそばに湧き水があって
その水を飲んでるんだから
おそらく長生きできているんではないかなと思いましょうと言っても
それ構いません いえ うちのそばにある湧き水に神様が憑いてるんだと
その神様のおかげでって言ったらもうアホなんですね
だから湧き水そのものに尊敬してください
そのものを大事にしてください
ありがたいと感謝しますと
守ってあげますと 汚らない
汚さないように気をつけますと
それは仏教的なんで 仏教は守ってくださいではない世界な守ります世界なんです
神様はこの湧き水を守ってくださいではなくて
私がお世話になってますから
私がみんなの協力を得てこの湧き水を守ります
という態度は仏教の仏教なんです
はい これで今日のポイントは
どんな生命の場合は人生と言いませんね
どんな生命の生涯も思考で出来上がっているんです
思考が作っているんです
しかし 私たちが思う通りにはいかないんですね
思考だったらね もっと格好よくなりたいでしょうね
もっと痩せたいとかね
もっと背が伸びた方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
もう鼻がもうちょっと伸びた方がいいやとか
あるいはちょっと縮んだ方が曲がった方がいいとかね
いろいろ人間には不満がありますよ
思っているんだけど そうはならないね
もうちょびっとこれより金ちょびっとあった方がいいんじゃない？とかね
希望はあるんです 考えもあるんです
うちの子はもうちょこっと勉強に精を出した方がいいと思いますけどとかね
希望とは反対の結果になることだけは日常茶飯事の経験ですね
それで私が言うことと我々の経験ってなんか反対ですね
私たちはいっぱい希望
希望っていうのは思考でしょ？いっぱい希望を持ってるし
いっぱい願い事があるしね
そういうのも希望も思考なんですね
でもその通りにいかないでしょ
だから希望通りにいかないということは
我々日常の経験ですけど
なのに私は全く違うことを今日言ってるんです
思考次第であると まずですから
思考について学んでみましょう
はい 思考とは 言葉で考えることだけではありません
私たちは思考と 我々一般人が
俗人が思考と言ったら
もう考えることなんですね
だってもう漢字見てもね
もう考えることだからね
それだけじゃないんですよ
思考とは心の仕事のことなんです
まあ車とは乗り物で 仕事は動くことでしょ
電車とは乗り物で 電車の仕事は動くことでしょう
そのようにいろんなものに自分に与えられたという言葉はおかしいんだけど
自分に何て言いますかね
定めた仕事があるんです
我々の目がありまして
これはもう外の情報 光の情報を感じる機械で
いくら音楽を目で聞くことはできません
わさびは美味しいかないかは目で味わうことはやめた方がいいでしょうね
ですから それぞれの部品に決まってる仕事があります
このマイクロフォンに自分の仕事があるんです
それやってる限りは OK
このマイクロフォン 突然歌い出しちゃったら困りますね
あるいは突然何て言いますかね
変な音をしますね あのキーというね
そういうものをしたら
あんた仕事をしなさいということで
いろいろ調整しなくちゃいけないんですね
はい 心の仕事を思考という言葉で私は今回の講演で使います
言葉がなくても概念がすべての生命にあります
言葉っていうのはほとんど人間ぐらいですよ
他我々知ってるね 他の動物たちなんかはね
まあたまにいくつかの単語を知ってるものもいますけど
概念あるんですね みんなに
私は犬猫やらどんな動物であろうか
もう何のことなく喋るんです
それもあの赤ちゃん言葉でもなく
子供向けの言葉でもなく
動物向けの言葉でもなく
対等で普通に大人使う言葉で喋るんです
あんたはねとかね なんで言うことを理解しないんですかねとかね
で そういうふうに対等で喋っても
みんな笑っちゃいますけど
私は馬鹿にしてね まあそれも狙いの一つかもしれませんだけど
わかるんですよ なんでわかるのかというと
私は言葉で言っていることと違って
概念で何か言ってるんですね
この概念が生じるんです
だから猫にいろんなこと言ってる
ただ馬鹿にしているだけは私のこととわかるんですね
あんたいい加減もう食って寝るんじゃなくて
真面目に何か仕事したらどうですかと
これ 猫にそういうふうにことを言うと
気持ち的には猫をからかってるだけなんですね
可愛がってからかってる
憎しみでからかってるわけじゃなくて
それはわかるんですね
それは理解して もう気にするもんか
何言われたってもという感じで
もうさらに悪いことしたりするんですね
だからそれで私 気持ちが通じてるんですね
この気持ちが通じるところは概念コンセプトなんですね
コンセプトには 概念には言葉はいりません
言葉なくても我々知ってることはたくさんあります
知ってるすべてのものに言葉あるわけじゃないんです
例えば体が痛くなったりするでしょ？まあ口で痛いというだけで
本当にそうですかね 痛みの種類っていうのは
もうあるわあるわあるわ
もう数えたことがないんだから
あの もう相当あるんですよ
でも知ってます 皆様も
ただ単純に足が痛いとか
お腹が痛いと胸が痛いとかいうだけでね
でも その胸が痛いと言ったっても
それもいろいろ痛みがあります
一部の痛みには言葉があるかもしれません
ほとんど言葉がないんです
でも我々よく知ってます
それが 概念があるんです
ということで で 言葉はいりません
思考するために 概念の回転も思考です
例えば 私たちは時々何も考えないで
あれやこれやとかやったりしているでしょう
何も考えないで部屋の掃除を掃除をしながら
まあ何も考えないではなくて
別なことを考えている
でも その時もちゃんと掃除機を判断して動かしているはずなんですね
完璧ではないかもしれませんだけど
ある程度で 例えばご飯食べながら喋っている
ちゃんとご飯も食べている
だからご飯について言葉で考えることはその時ないんです
その時 言葉ではないんだけど
何を取ったか もうソースを入れたかないかちゃんとやってるんです
そういえばあの人ですねと言いながら
パンにバターを塗ってるんですよ
それもちょうど自分の好みぐらいに合わせて
だからそこをちゃんと思考が起きてるんですよ
でも言葉が使ってないんですね
感情の回転も心の働きなので
ここでは思考とします
で 概念の回転 それから感情の回転
それは心の仕事なんです
感情っていうのは 仏教用語では煩悩ですからね
まあ怒ったら次から次
次から次へと怒り 怒りを作るんです
欲が出たら次から次へと
次から次へと色々もうデータ集めて欲を回転させる
そこで集める必要もないんです
なんか心のファンクションというのは
機能っていうのはなんか面白くて
ほとんどなんか自動で整理整頓するような
なんかもう最近のね パソコンみたいなデータバンクみたいなもんで
もう勝手に整理整頓してくるというね
あれ 整理整頓ではなくてインデクシングなんですけど
例えば怒りが現れたら
怒りに関連する様々な概念
データ 過去の経験 サッとつなげてくるんです
私たちは一度たりとも怒った
もっと怒らなくちゃいけない
もっと怒るためにはどうしよう
こいつは他やった悪いことなかったっけ？とか考えたことがある？ないんです
欲の場合でも あの子は結構可愛いんだけど
もっと可愛いと思う方法ないのかとかね
ないんですよ そんなことは
あれは自動的に起こるんです
起こった瞬間で そういえばこの人はあの日はこんなことやったとかね
そういえば 33年前  3月
3月 3月 28日 7時半でこういうことをやったとかね
サッと出てくるんですよ
このものの見事に この頭の良さ
だからそれは心の仕事
だから心の仕事は私の希望で起きて起きてないでしょう
希望で起きてないんです
怒りたいなあとか思って怒ることは不可能です
それは心の訓練している人にはできますけど
あまり面倒くさいんだからやらない
普通はそうじゃない 怒りたい
怒りたいと思って怒るんじゃなくて
心がちょぴっとした経験に合わせて
サッと必要なデータを瞬時にまとめてくれて
とことん怒りを回転させちゃう
で 欲を回転させる 落ち込みを回転させる
嫉妬を回転させる それは感情というんですね
そうやって感情の回転も私がここで思考というんです
本当は私の思考の定義は心の働きなんですね
ジョブディスクリプションオブマインドなんです
心のジョブディスクリプション
仕事の内容   それをまとめて思考っていう簡単な言葉を使ったんです
思考が人生のありさまを作り出します
この思考がもうわかっているでしょう
我々の人生を作るんです
だって自分は希望として怒りたくないんだけども
怒っているんだからね
どうしますか 人生は起こったことによってそれなりの結果出します
例えば 希望としては嫉妬しないんだけど
もう嫉妬しているんですね
心はその仕事をしているんです
勝手に 私の管理きかないんです
ああ 嫉妬してはいけません
もう頑張って嫉妬しないようにと
無理ですね やっぱり自分の管理きかないんです
それで心が勝手に思考して人生を作るんです
はい これで思考の 3つの層があるんです
ちょびっと難しいかも
1私たちが気づいている思考と感情
これは表面表面としましょう
それは皆様知っています
今考えているでしょう
もしかすると講演中だから考えないこと
寝ることにしているかもしれませんだけど
だったら講演聞かないで別なことでも考えていると思います
それは気づくんでわかるんですね
それから自分が怒ってくると
眠くなってくると 気分が悪くなってくると
面白くなってくると 面白くなくなってくると感じる
わかるでしょ それは表面層ですね
たまに気づく無意識と言われる感情の層
それは背面です この無意識という単語は仏教用語ではありません
これは現代心理学の用語です
心にこの背面もありますね
この背面にはたまに気づくんです
我々は  3番目持って生まれる基礎の層ベーシックレイヤー
これは仏教用語で潜在煩悩と言うんです
パーリ語ではアヌッセと言うんです
この 3層です どんな生命も生まれると
この基礎層を持っているんですね
これはもう生まれ変わったってもどうしようもないんです
ここを間違って  これは皆様に関係ないんだけど
唯識論を語る仏教では阿頼耶識と言いますけど
阿頼耶識の説明はヒンドゥー教っぽくて
ウパニシャッドっぽくて
もうあれは仏教じゃないんですけどね
お釈迦様の言葉ではアヌッセ
寝ている煩悩という言葉ですね
はい 次 あの思考の働き方の前のスライドの説明はもっと必要でしょうかなと
あまり必要でもないんだけど
まあ例は出せないんですね
この 3番目は誰にも気づくことはできません
1は知ってます  2にもたまに気づく
例えば この精神的な このカウンセリングを受ける場合は
カウンセラーがいろいろ話を聞いて質問して
この人が口で言わない精神状態も発見しますね
だから無意識 無意識で言っているんですね
で  3番目はもう ベーシックレイヤーだから
それはもう誰にも発見することはできません
気づくこともできません
仏教の世界だけで ブッダの心理学を学んで調べる人にだけ
まあいろいろ実験して
いろんな工夫をして おそらくこうではないかというふうに発見することはできます
仏教世界以外はできません
はい 次のスライドに行きます
思考の働き方 欲 怒り 落ち込みなどの感情で思考する
大体私たちは思考するって偉そうなことじゃないんですよ
ほとんどみんな欲で怒りで落ち込みで傲慢で思考しているんですよ
もう科学を研究する人も
数学を一生懸命学ぶ子供も
もう誰だって感情ですよ
私はずっと数学は 100点で来たんだから
もう 100点にならなくちゃ恥ずかしいやとか
一生懸命プライドを持って頑張りますから
結局は感情が絡んで思考しているんです
科学を研究する人々も
やっぱり感情が入って研究しているんです
知識 教育 仕事 人付き合いなどで思考する
そこで知識を得る時は考えているんですね
でも裏で感情が入っている
教育の場合も考えなきゃ教育ではないでしょう
教育を受ける人は考えているんです
が 感情が入っているんです
仕事をする時でも思考するでしょう
その時も必ず感情が入って思考しているんです
人付き合い まあいろいろ毎日考えているんだからね
表面の思考は裏面の感情に影響を与える
これがポイントです 頭の表面で
心の表面で 我々は怒ったり
欲があったり もう傲慢があったり
見栄があったり 知ってます
今 自分が今見栄でこれ言ってるんだとかね
今欲で仕事をしているんだとか
今もう相手に対して憎しみを持って仕事をしているんだとかね
知ってます しかし この表面でのからくりで心が仕事をしているんだから
この仕事の結果が背面の層にだ
2番目の層に入るんです
無意識に入るんです ですから
無意識が変わるんです
意識の働きで すべて無常だから
ずっと変わりつつなんです
裏面の感情の変化が基礎感情にも影響を与える
それで我々の無意識ののも性格も変わると
すべて作っている基礎層
それ気づくことできない
潜在の潜在ところ そちらも変わるんです
だから怒ってこら あんた何やってるの？って言っただけでは済みませんよ
それは無意識にも影響を与えて
無意識の裏にある あの性にも
基本 OS にも 影響 与えるんです
パソコン用語で言えば
我々使っているソフトウェアが我々は自由自在に使っているんだから管理できる
しかし ウィンドウズかマッキントッシュのソフトウェアだったら
OS は我々に管理できません
会社が権力を握っているんですね
ウィンドウズの場合は
マッキントッシュ マイクロソフト会社とアップルコンピューターパソコン買ったら
もう Apple iOS はその会社を管理しているんですね
しかし どんなパソコンが Apple であろうか
ウィンドウズであろうか
電子部品ですからね この電子部品は動く言語があるんですね
それをバイアスとバイアスというんですね
あの ビーアイ  BIOS ですね
それは誰もいじりません
で パソコン部品を作る会社たちは
このなんとか単語ありますね
あれは何ウェアというんですかね
ファームウェアといってね
そのプログラムを入れて売ってるんです
それは誰も触りませんし
どんなものかと知ることもできません
私たち一般人には ウィンドウズ7は 8 はどうなっているかもわからない
しかし よく見てください
私たちがプログラム いろんなものをワープロとかに作ったりしていて
これで特にゲームとかね
メールとかね あるいはこの怪しいサイトとかにね
アクセスしたりしていると
パソコンが変なに変なものになっちゃうんですね
そこからウィンドウズに穴を開けるんです
私たちにできないんです
一般人には で 私たちはいじってるプログラムからウィンドウズという OS に穴が開けるんです
壊れるんです 本当のところ OK
ボタンを押したのは自分なんです
サイトにアクセスするボタンを押したのは自分なんです
無知でアホで押しちゃったんですね
押ったところでグジッとこんなのが入っちゃってしがみつくんで
そこで OS 壊れていくと
バイアスも壊れるんです
なかなか壊れませんだけど
壊れるんです バイアス壊れると
このパソコンを作った会社にお願いして
バイアスアップデートプログラムを入れて
特別なやり方で入れ替えなくちゃあかんですね
だからなんかパソコンの構造を見ると心の構造となんか似ているような感じで
3 重構造なんですね バイアスという構造があって
その上にウィンドウズという OS があって
その上にワープロやら表計算やら
いろんなものはゲームやら一番上にあるんで
一番上にあるものは我々は自由に使っているんです
しかし あの 2つの構造がなければアウト
何もできません これは誰にも理解できる働きです
3 重構造でね 一応これ誰にでも理解できますよ
難しくないんです 私たちは毎日朝から晩まで考えたりすることによって人格が変わるでしょう
毎日の感情によって人生が変わるでしょう
小さい時はすごく未練
未練ではなくて 見込みがある
将来性のある若者でしたけど
今こんなもんやと 今こんなもんっていうのは誰がやったんですかね
本人の思考と感情なんです
すごく勉強できる頭のいい子であっても
犯罪者である可能性はあります
それは日々の思考と感情によって表面が変わって
表面で裏面が変わって
裏面で基礎層が変わったんです
もう壊れちゃったんで
人生は はい  2番目の働き方
この 1番目の働き方は誰でもわかります
裏面の感情が表面の感情を刺激する
時々あの外から何のこともないんだけど
なんとなく自分の心の中から嫌な気持ちが湧いてくる
怒りが湧いてくる 欲が湧いてくる
あるんですよ 時々 別に理由はないんです
朝 普通に目が覚めたんだけど
なんか嫌で嫌で 誰かを蹴っ飛ばしたいという気分でいるんですね
それであんたに誰かが何か悪いことをして
いえ 何も誰もやってないんですが
気分がもうブルーですね
何も起きてないのに それ
裏面なんですね 裏面の感情がちょっと興奮しちゃったんです
大体寝ている時 よく起こります
だから赤ちゃんときっちゃな子供たちのを理解しなきゃ育てられないでしょ
だからどんな性格の人かと理解した方がいいんです
子供に聞いたっても 子供は喋れませんからね
よくわかりやすい方法っていうのは目覚めなんです
寝ている時 体を見る 顔を見る
寝ている時の体 手足 顔の表情と寝ている姿
それから目覚める瞬間で見る
その時 あの裏の層が刺激して表面に影響を与えているんです
それで心の中いくらか読めます
人の性格を知る方法はそれなんです
だから皆様もバレますから
人の家で寝ないでください
で 目覚める時は今まで普通社会生活で隠している性格は
もう出ているんです それに反応して表面の感情が思考妄想を作る
そこでこの裏の層が波打っちゃうと
表の我々知ってる意識層も似て似た波を打っちゃうんですね
それで何のこともなく人を怒鳴ったりする
家族の中でよく起こることなんですよ
万なら奥さんに怒鳴ったりとか
別に奥さんが何か悪いこと言っても何もやってないんです
夫婦喧嘩って結構その裏面のあれで怒る場合はあるんですね
だからこの怒りが興奮しちゃうと
もう表面にも入っちゃって
もう奥さんを怒鳴ったりしてたりする
あるいは奥さんが優しい人だから
なんか旦那のことをもうちょっと優しくしなくちゃいけないとか
無意識で夜考えたりして
で 目が覚めるとそれは意識に入ってるんですね
そうすると やけに旦那さんに親切に愛情を持ってしゃべってると
なんだお前はと言って
またすれちゃうんで その場合は
それで夫婦喧嘩になって
かなり問題が起こるんですね
旦那さんから見ると 特別やけに親切にする必要はない
そんな何かあったわけでもないし
何かプレゼントをあげたわけでもないし
夜自分がすごい遅くなって帰ってましたし
そのまま寝ちゃったしね
奥さんもそれ知らない
何のことなく自分でも知らないんだけど
いきなりやけに旦那さんに朝親切に対応する
前の日は全く親切ではなかったんだけど
だからそういう風にこの感情があって
これは相手と合わないんだからね
結構トラブル起こるんです
はい そこまで考えなくてもいいんですが
我々のこの無意識のところの感情が波を打っちゃうと
それは表面に 表面に影響を与える
だからこれがよく夜起こるんです
寝ている時は 寝ている時は見ることも聞くことも考えることもしないんですね
寝ているんです しかし心は寝ないんだから
そうすると 主に表面ではなくて裏面が仕事をするんです
新たに現れる感情が表面の裏面の感情と基礎感情に影響を与える
そこでどうなったかというと
この無意識が波を打って意識にコンタクト
連絡する そこで意識で考える
意識で考えたり 感情を作ったりする
この波が激しいんですね
それがまた真ん中の層と一番下の層に影響を与えるんです
で 最初に説明したのは
意識層が仕事をして 上のね
意識層が仕事をして その影響は 2番目に3番目に下へ下へ行くこと
今説明しているのは 真ん中の層が波を打っちゃって
上に連絡して 上が波を打っちゃって思考すると
そこエネルギーが真ん中に入って
真ん中から一番底にある層に入るんです
私たちはだいたいこの人の性格って
この思考の働き方についてなんです
だから あんまり世の中はこの 2番目の思考の働き方
勉強していないんだから
あんまり人の性格もよくわからないんですね
性格分析やらね 性格のいろんなダイアグラム書いたり
いろいろやってはいるんだけどね
はい  3番目に行きましょう
思考の働き方  3 突然 基礎感情が潜在状態から目覚める
これは誰もわからない
なんでやと だって潜在煩悩だから知らないんです
気づかないんです 有意識論で言っている
荒い意識なんです こいつは突然目が覚めるんです
目が覚めて その感情 目が覚めると
恐ろしいですよ この基本的なものだからね
すぐ真ん中にいる裏面に影響を与える
裏面がどんどん波打っちゃうと
表面の心にそれがいっちゃうんです
言って私たち知ってる思考するんです
知ってる感情するんです
裏の感情を刺激する それに反応して
表の感情と思考が働き出す
また 裏の感情と基礎感情に影響を与える
問題はこのフィードバックなんです
いつでも心は自分でフィードバックをするんです
はい 画像で考えてください
下のレベルが波を打っちゃうと
真ん中のレベルの波を打つんですね
そうすると上の方が激しい波を打つんです
上が激しい波を打っちゃうと
その影響は真ん中にいって
真ん中から下へまで行くんです
そういうことで 心というのはいつでも自給自足で頑張っているんです
これは一般的に理解できない働きです
一般人には無理 でもあの
いるでしょう 時々どうしても人を殺したいとか突然考える連中が
長い間計画を立てたわけじゃないんです
嫌な人がいて あいつを殺してやりたいと
結構考えて考えて計画を立てて人を殺したわけじゃなくて
とにかく人を殺したい
誰でも関係ない 誰と人を殺したい
そういうケースは日本でもよくたまに起こるし
西洋でも起こるんです
欲だけの世界で生きているんだからね
この経済大国の連中には
食うことと金を儲けること
儲かること以外 もう何の知恵もないんだからね
いかに儲かるか いかに儲かるかと
だからそういうふうな動物みたいな人間が現れちゃうんです
貧乏でもいいんじゃないかと
仲良く生活すればっていう考えはないんです
そういうわけで 突然人を殺したとかね
突然あれ なんだろう 痴漢したとかね
もしかするとそれがこの潜在煩悩が波打っちゃって
サラサラッと上に行ったんです
問題は 潜在煩悩が波を打っちゃうと必ず上に行くんです
地震と同じです 地震が起きると
建物が揺れないようにすることは不可能ですね
しかし 台風で物事を動かしたり壊れたりする場合は
私たちにはある程度で自分の家の窓を閉めて
窓を閉じて中を守ることはできます
窓を開けておいちゃうと
ドアを開けておいたら台風が入っちゃって
もう中のものはぐちゃぐちゃ
もうもしかするとね タンスやら本棚やらね
食器棚倒したりする可能性もありますね
で 無理なの 竜巻のような強烈な場合なんですね
しかし 地震で家が揺れること
どうやって止めますか？これは無理です
なぜならば 地面の一番下からこの振動が来るんです
表面からじゃないんです
あの この畑 田んぼあるところで
ノゾミなんか走っちゃうと
周りがずっと振動入るんですよ
地面にも入ります でも表だけ
裏に行かないんです 地震の場合は地層の一番下ですよ
揺れるのは どうしようもないんです
そこで地震がいつ起こるかと誰にも言うことはできないんです
その技術はないんです
そのように潜在煩悩が目覚めるのはどんな時かと
これは言うことはできないんです
推測できない 推測 予測できません
かなり危険です しかし
地震の場合も あらゆる機械を作って作って
下の中に埋めて いろんな電波主流とかね
計算したりしますね まあ地震起こるぞと
まあ大体まあ 1 分前とか 30 秒前とか
知ることはできますけど
そんな時間知ったってどうったことないしね
じゃあ 1 日前に知ったんだからってどうしますか
どうしようもないでしょ
そういうわけで このスライドに入ってないんだから普通に言いますけど
私たちはこの毎日怒ったりすると
この怒りが真ん中の層に無意識に入るでしょ
無意識から潜在意識に入るでしょ
そうやって影響を与えて
このフィードバックというかね
やってると 目覚める可能性はありますね
潜在層が あれは潜在だから寝ているのは基本なんです
パソコンのバイアスは絶対ユーザーにとはコンタクトを取らない
パソコンを新しく起動するときは
バイアスプログラムを入れ替えるならば F2
とか 4 とか押してくださいと出てきます
その時もプログラムがあって
どちらどちらするのかと決めるだけで
あまり大胆なことはできません
してはいけません はい
そういうわけで 私たちの毎日の生活ぶりから
この潜在煩悩がたまに目覚めたりする可能性はあります
このたまに目覚めることは
精神的な自信のようなものなんです
決していいことじゃないんです
潜在煩悩が寝た方が安心です
そこで私は仏教の心理学だから
煩悩 煩悩 煩悩という言葉を使ってます
で この心の構造が根本的に良くないっていうのは仏教の立場なんです
えーと 思考の働き方さん
なぜあの人はこんなことをしたのかよくわからないとするしか
その場合はね 潜在煩悩が働きだったら
専門家にも理解 理由を見つけることはできません
なんで突然人が誰でもいいんだからこうしたんでしょうかと調べても
調べても理由が見つからないんです
脳に問題があったり 麻薬などの影響で行う意味不明な行動はこのカテゴリーではありません
時々わけのわからないことは脳に異常があるときもしますね
それはこの潜在煩悩じゃないんです
だって お医者さんに言えば
この人の脳がちょっとおかしいとちゃんと見つかるんだから
潜在煩悩っていうのはそんなもんじゃないんです
あるいは麻薬などで脳が壊れちゃって変なことをしますよ
わけもわからないこと
それでもお医者さんが知ってます
解明できます この解明できるものは潜在煩悩ではないんです
カテゴリーではありません
理由はわかりますから
はい これで 3番目の思考の方法ですね
はい 次のタイトルは人格を変える思考
軽い気持ちで思考するが
感情は刺激を受けます
我々は考えるときはね
本当にもう無責任で もう何でも考えちゃいますね
でも感情は刺激を受けます
それによって無意識レベルの働きも変わります
その変化によって基礎感情も変わるんです
あの寝ているやつも 寝ていても変わります
すべての生命は貪瞋痴をさらに刺激する方法で思考します
生命はこの感情っていうのは 1,500あるんだけど
全部悪いもんなんですよ
まとめたら貪瞋痴ですね
どんな生命も貪瞋痴が増える方法へ思考するんです
したがって性格が悪くなります
徐々に不幸になります
だから思考次第ですが
我々は不幸になるように決まっているんです
感情のせいで どんな思考をしても
最終的には不幸になっているんです
悩み 苦しみが増します
これって恐ろしいシステムなんです
例えば ある人がね 私は幸せになりたい
とか なんとかとかね 豊かになりたいとかね
思ったっても欲の感情でしょ
時々いますよ 人の役に立つことをしたいとかね
優しい人間なんですけど
でも繊細運動がね 欲なんです
もしかすると怒り ですから
結局は最終的に大した幸福には達しません
難しいんです 道徳とは
戒めが必要です ですから
幸福になりたければ戒めが必要です
道徳とは貪瞋痴を抑える努力のことです
仏教心理学的に道徳の定義とは
貪瞋痴をなんとか抑えること
貪瞋痴 三重三重構造で働いています
Three layers
繊細基礎層で貪瞋痴が働いています
無意識のところでも貪瞋痴が働いています
意識でも貪瞋痴が働いています
仲がいいんです ぴったしはめるんです
この 3層がすれないんです
ぴったしヒットする人もいて与えているんです
それで仏教は推薦するんです
貪瞋痴を制御しなさいと
抑えるようにしてくださいと
難しいかもしれませんよ
でも頑張れと それが道徳なんです
だから断言的に言いますけど
道徳は仏教にあるんです
神は汝殺すなかれと言われて
神が恐れて人を殺さないことっていうのはいいことだけで
そんなに道徳的な大したことないんです
本物の道徳は 自分の心にある感情
貪瞋痴をコントロールすることです
それに私たちは嘘を言わないように頑張るわ
生命を殺さないように頑張るわ
酒を飲まないようにいろいろ頑張りますけどね
でも裏はこの働きなんです
例えば欲を抑えるために
我々出家はね まあ大罪しませんし
性行為はしないんですね
性行為はしない 頭が欲ばっかしで性欲ばっかしだったら意味がないでしょう
体で何もやってないだけでは
自分の国ではもうもうもう
誰かが私は菜食主義 肉魚食べませんと言った途端
私はものすごく嫌な気分になるんです
こいつは信頼できないインチキ野郎やと
この前行きましたから
堂々と言うんです こんな表面で何かやって
裏でやっていること 政治家もいるんで
何人かは ありとあらゆるもう世にみんなびっくりするほど悪いことをやりながら
自分がまあちゃんと まあすごい仏教的で
肉魚も食べないで で 豚よりも太って
それでも だから表面的なところも必要ですけど
それより 心の問題なんです
だから仏教のお釈迦様の世界では
在家で家族を持って子供を育てている普通の人々も
預流果に不還果に悟っていたんですよ
アナートピンディカこっちがもう商人ですよ
銀行員です 人に金を貸してあげて
利息をバンバン取ってるんです
しかし預流果に悟っているんです
子供もたくさんいたし
孫もたくさんいたし だからそういう人々はすごく立派な方々で
貪瞋痴を抑えているんですね
お釈迦様のおじ様一人がいた
一人だけなんですけど
酒飲むんです 酒飲む 賭け事をする
それで釈迦族のみんな嫌で嫌で
我々は釈迦族 我々は偉大なる少学者を作った民族ですと
だから私たちは少学者の生き方にふさわしい
恥じないように生きていかなくちゃかんと
みんな完璧に戒律を守って
五戒を守って生活している
釈迦族みんな一人だけ
お釈迦さんのおじいさんです
その一人 酒飲む 賭け事をする OK
だからね もうそれなりの財産もあったでしょうね
そこでお釈迦様より随分年上のおじい様がいて
もう国を治めていたのはその人で
お釈迦様とはよく話すんですね
まあだってお釈迦様は本当に相続者だからね
右端だから で 話している時は
ある日 お釈迦様はこれ恥ずかしいんだからね
私たちにとっては あのおじいさんに何か言ってくださいと
言ってもお釈迦様は何も言わない
それでこの人は亡くなったんです
亡くなったところで亡くなったと連絡が入ったら
お釈迦様は その人は預流果に悟った人であると
だから決して地獄には落ちませんと
人間に戻ったっても 七回で終了で解脱に達しますよと言った途端
釈迦族はびっくりしちゃって
なんとことですかと これはと
あの酔っ払いがと 言ってマハーナーマ王がお釈迦様にあの言葉を撤回してくださいと頼むんです
困りますと お釈迦様は撤回しません
かっかしたんです 悟ってるんだと
だからお釈迦様は逆に表面的な生き方に何も言わなかったんです
中身はできてたんです
もしかすると その人は体質的に酒が好きでしたかもしれませんし
自分の社会の状況によって賭け事とかしたりする
しなきゃまずい状態に置かれていた可能性もある
商売上 でも心ではちゃんと仏教を理解して
中は違う だから本当の道徳っていうのは
そういうふうに感情を清らかにすることなんです
表面のしきたりではないんです
欲 怒り 憎しみ 落ち込みなどが減らすように努めることです
人は思考してから体 言葉
考えるという行為をします
我々は体で行為します
言葉で行為します 考えることで行為します
その行為する前に思考するんです
だから思考ひたすらなんです
身口意の行為を仏教が教えるように制御するならば
貪瞋痴の働きが弱くなっていきます
お釈迦様は言葉こうやって管理しなさい
考えるときはこういうふうに考えなさい
体はこういうふうに使ってくださいと言われている
十悪 十善ありますからね
それぐらい守れば 十善十悪には酒が入ってないんです
この五戒っていうのはちょっともう儀式っぽいですね
戒律項目っていうのはね
お釈迦様 最初は戒律項目を作りたくないという状態でいたんです
その代わりに善と悪をとくんです
でも 面倒くさい人間がバカで言うことはしないし
間違うし そうすると命令で殺生しないことを戒めますとかね
嘘を言わないことを戒めますとかね
もう項目出てくるんですね
はい これで心の構造がわかったところで
仏教が何するのかというと
この心の構造は根本的に間違っているんだから
これ改良することを提案しているんです
ただの心理学じゃないんです
仏教心理学は 心理学の場合はこれ外科なんですね
心の だからお釈迦様は自分のことをはっきり外科という言葉を使っているんです
私がもう 偉大なる外科であると
いわゆるこの上のない外科であると
外科っていう言葉なんて使ったんですかね
なんで内科が悪いんですかね
一番治療するのは内科でしょうに
やっぱり心の構想根本から変えるんです
外科的な治療です すべての生命は貪瞋痴は本能です
タイトルは貪瞋痴っていうのは生命の本能です
すべての生命の本能は貪瞋痴です
貪瞋痴を応援したいのです
誰だって しかし すべての不幸を司る働きは貪瞋痴です
我々は欲を応援したいでしょ
で 世の中はまあ欲怒りを応援する場合はかなり人気があるんです
しかし それで不幸になるんです
貪瞋痴は苦を作ります
輪廻転生の原因です 布団不尽
不痴は苦に対する解毒剤です
ですから 我々は布団不尽
不痴を無理やり心に入れなくちゃいけないんです
心のこの自動フィードバックシステムを変えなくちゃあかんのです
心は自動的に自分でフィードバックして栄養を作っているんですね
これ 何とかして邪魔して破らなくちゃあかんのです
だから布団不尽 不痴というものを入れるんです
はい 次 思考 心の創造力
思考は全知全能の神様よりも力を持っています
あなたのすべてを思考が決めます
創造者ですよ 思考は はい
このテーマでいきます
思考の創造力 体の構成
維持管理 寿命の管理 病気になるかならないかを決めること
人生のすべての幸福 成功
失敗などなどのすべてが思考次第です
皆様の体の形も決めたのは皆様の思考なんです
背がどれぐらい伸びるのかと
その思考が決めるんです
遺伝子に問題があっても
がんになる欠陥があっても
がんになるか がんにしないのかと思考が決めるんです
ウイルスに感染しても
病気になるかならないか思考決めるんです
物質ではありません だから世の中はそれをわかってないんです
この白血病とかね もう最初は何もないのに
後で現れてる場合もあります
年取ってくると誰だってガンにかかる可能性多いでしょ
長い間貪瞋痴で生きてきたんだからなんです
貪瞋痴を抑えて抑えてきてたならば
大体じゃあがんになることを延期します
後回しにします それでその先に死にますから大丈夫です
しかし 潜在煩悩にかなり強烈な何か貪瞋痴の何かあったら
それもわからないんです
だからすごく生活の良い人も
時々不幸になったり 短命になったり
突然病気になって死んだりする可能性もありますね
その場合は潜在煩悩に何かあったんですね
潜在煩悩はアクセス不可能なセクションなんです
というわけで 食べたご飯がちゃんと体の栄養になるか
あるいはこれを脂肪に回すか
心を最初に決めるんです
思考が最初に決めるんです
だから これは生まれる前から思考パターンを持ってるんだからね
どうしようもないんです
生まれる時 遺伝子がね
親と両親の遺伝子が組み換わ組み替える時も
組み替えと言わないね
合わせる時も大量に遺伝子あるんだけどね
あるセットで決めちゃうんです
だから兄弟 互い違うでしょ
同じ遺伝子を持ってるんだけど
これ心をやってるんです
思考がやってるんです
しかし 私たちに思考管理ができないんです
できれば一番ありがたいでしょう
思考はしっかり管理できれば
これは普通できなくなってます
仏教が 仏教とはこれを教える教えなんです
宗教を教えているんじゃないんです
いかに思考を管理するのかと
思考は自分勝手に働きます
だから俗世間でもいう
仏教でもいう希望は叶いませんよという言葉が現れるんです
だって思考は勝手だから
でも法則は法則 あなたの人生はあなたの思考次第です
あなたはどのように思考するのか
あなたはそのようになると
それで運命って何ですか？と
皆 物事が希望通りにいかない時
運命 神の定めの決まり
戦争のたたりなど なんとかの妄想概念で納得します
時々キリスト教の方々にはね
白血病の子供なんか生まれたら納得するんです
それはもうどうしようもない
もう神様がとか 何かお決まりになっているでしょうと納得
可愛いお母ちゃんが先に死んじゃったら
あ 神様に呼ばれましたと
もう納得 バカじゃないかと
悲しいでしょうに 子供が先に死ぬのは
基礎の潜在煩悩の状況を少学者にしか理解することはできません
この理由は この世の中の人間が
この潜在煩悩については全く知らないんです
ユングとかもね なんとかもうなんかコモンコンシャスな
なんだかんだ変な言葉いろいろ使ってますけどね
みんなお互いにコンシャスなつながっているところがあるんだとか
もうそちらからパクったアイデアばっかしでね
あんまりまとめてないんですよ
誰一人もこの潜在煩悩のことを知らないんです
我々は宇宙の意識で管理しているわけじゃないんです
ただ 個人の心の煩悩に似ているだけ
似てるだけ 似ているものつながります
それだけです ユニバーサルコンシャスネスというものはないんです
では この潜在煩悩のことをわかるのは少学者だけです
お釈迦様だけです だからこの瞑想を指導するときに
はお釈迦様は一回だけ
お釈迦様が人に朝瞑想する方法を教えたら
その人はもう五千中悟っちゃうんです
時々お釈迦様が説法しているだけで
説法あるともう悟っているんです
これはもうサーリプッタ尊者にもできません
誰にもできません 私は説法したら悟るところが仏教が大嫌いやと言って
もう逃げちゃうんです
そういうわけで あの お釈迦様の場合は
この全部心のこの構造を知って指示しているんです
この能力をお釈迦様だけにあるということに一つエピソードがあります
サーリプッタ尊者のエピソードなんですけど
サーリプッタ尊者が智慧第一人者だから
ある金の作業する人がね
金細工細 何でしたっけ？ゴールドスミス
金の職人 宝石作るね で
若者が嫌になっちゃって出家しちゃったんですね
そこでサーリプッタ尊者が
この人はすごい心立派な人で
あの瞑想を教えてあげましょうと
で 考えたんです この人は金持ちとしか付き合ったことはない
王家の人々と大金持ち
だって金のアクセサリーを作るのはそういう人々だけでしょ
それから美人ばっかし見たことでしょう
それから朝から晩までものすごく美しい金のものばっかり見て
きれいな花を作ったり
いろんなアクセサリー作ったりしているんです
だから この人にはものすごく欲がある
ですから不浄の瞑想をさせた方がいい
裏面を見せた方がいいと思って
不浄の瞑想を教えたんです
これやってくださいと
この人は真面目に瞑想するはするはするは全く集中力が生まれません
嫌になったんです それで本人が
うん 私は真剣 真面目に修行しました
しかし微塵も成長しなかったということは
私には資格はありません
帰らなくちゃと還俗しなくちゃと思ったんです
その時 お釈迦様は何のことなく
なんでお前落ち込んでるんですかと
ただ 実際 お釈迦様 まあこういうことで
私はもう悟れないんだと
失格だと だから悲しいんだけど
還俗しますと ああそう
まあそれはまあ後でもいいでしょうと言って
お釈迦様はこいつにものすごい綺麗なさっと花をね
普通のハスの花ですね
これ持ちなさい お釈迦様からもらったんだからね
これあげますから これ持って
ちょっとじーっとこれ見ていてくださいと
この人 お釈迦様からいただいた完璧な花を見て
ものすごく喜んじゃったんです
なんて美しいでしょうと
なんか凍ってしまったんですね
そのままじーっと見ているんです
今まで不浄ばっかり わけもわからない不浄のことばっかり考えていたんだから
それは能力ないんで 不浄の見る能力が脳に
あれを見たらもう専門家だから
きちっともう固まったんですね
心が それで見ていると
綺麗にあの花が枯れていくんです
変化していくんです それであの釘付けた心も一緒に変わって変わっていったんです
それで花びらが枯れて
ぽすんぽすんと落ちると
本人はああ すべて捨てるべきものであると
で 心から煩悩が全部落ちてしまったんです
すぐあっという間に悟りに達したんです
お釈迦様はあまり大したことをしなかったんです
すごい気楽に ああ まあ還俗することはまあいつだってできるでしょう
ちょっと待って この花を持ってください
それだけ だから直々お釈迦様が優しく言葉をかけてくれたんだから
そのありがたみもあって
でも悟ったんですね だからお釈迦様の神通あるんだから
ある程度で早く花が枯れてしまった可能性もあります
はい そこで説明しているのは
この なんで偉大なるサーリプッタ尊者
智慧の第一人者にできなかったんですかと
阿羅漢になる人なのに
それは潜在煩悩は読めないんだからなんです
うん 潜在煩悩を読めないんです
お釈迦様にしか読めないんです
だから世の中で神が神々がいるわ
悪魔がいるわ まあいろいろいるでしょう
神もたくさんの ヒンドゥー教ではものすごいたくさんの神がいるわ
アッラがいるわ エホバいるわ
イエススがいるわ マリアがいるわね
それから聖人と言うんですかね
まあいろんな連中がいるわ
もういろんなものを作って作って作って
自分の運命を理解しようと納得しようとしているんですね
無駄な努力です そんなのは勘違いです
潜在煩悩の働きがわからないからなんです
しかし 理由は潜在煩悩だとわからないので
迷信を作って納得します
だから世の中迷信だらけなんです
インド人 スリランカ人が星占いを知じているんです
私は最後の説法でスリランカから出る前に
はちゃめちゃ お前らほど馬鹿な無知な連中がもう世の中にいないんだよと
あれも信仰する これも信仰する
神々も信仰する 占いも信仰する
なんだこりゃと あれ厳しく言ったんです
結果はさらに信仰を続ける
潜在煩悩ってかなり頑丈です
基礎感情層は簡単にわかりません
裏無意識の感情も簡単に変わりません
大体そんな簡単に変わりません
意識的な感情を管理することが努力するならばできます
我々に唯一できるのは
この意識で管理することなんです
かなり頑丈ですよ しかし
煩悩が人生を支配しています
ですから 性格は常に変化していますが
それは改良ではありません
変化のみです 我々は瞬間瞬間変化しています
でも改良はしないんです
で 意識でね 意図的に怒り
嫉妬 憎しみを抑えることで変わりますよ
でも我々は貪瞋痴に支配されているんだから
やらないんです まあ明日やりますと
知ってる人も明日にします
そういうことになっているんです
人格改良の鍵 意識している
いわゆる気づいているね
表面の思考構造を構造が鍵です
まあ至って簡単 我々知っている意識
それが鍵です 表面で現れる貪瞋痴の制御できます
あの頭の怒りが出たら
そこは できますよ コントロールすること
欲ができたら じゃあ頑張ります
欲はなくすようにと それはできます
だから 意識でコントロールすればいいんです
妄想を減らすことも 思考を制御することもできます
それぐらいはできますよ
これをやるとどうなりますか？ 2番目の無意識の方が影響を受けるんです
無意識が影響を受けると
潜在が影響を受けるんです
妄想を減らすこともね
妄想って貪瞋痴の刺激ですからね
考えるところも貪瞋痴が刺激するんだから
お釈迦様はこれこれ考えなさい
これこれ考えなさいではなくて
これこれだけは考えてはいけませんと決めてますから
そういうところをコントロールすると
まあうまくいきますよ
表面を制御することと
裏面のすると裏面に影響が入りますね
さらに努力すると基礎煩悩層にも影響を与えます
これでどんどんどんどんこの手術作業が起こるんです
で 管理の仕方 思考と感情を管理する方法はたくさん説かれています
だから 意識的な思考をどうやって管理するのかという方法というのは
たくさん経典の中にあるんです
気づき サティの実践は究極の方法です
その中でも皆さんはそれを知っている
もう一つの方法は 汚れた思考を正しい思考で置き換えること
それで我々の思考が汚れていますね
貪瞋痴で思考しているんだから
それで正しい思考を入れて置き換える
それも中部経典で特別な経典があります
思考を置き換える経典というね
タイトルまで 問題は 誰もが自分の思考は正しいと思っていることです
これが問題なんです だから
あなたの思考が間違っているんだから
正しい思考に置き換えてくださいと言ったっても
自分が自分の思考を正しいと思っているんだからね
もうとんでもないことになっちゃうんです
これが大きな問題なんです
ですから 正しい思考とは何かと学ばなくてはならないんです
勝手に考えてはあかん
私は正しい思考をしていると思っては意味がないんです
誰だって間違った思考しないんですよ
本人には正しいんです
自分の思考は だから 自分だけの力で間違った思考を正しい思考で置き換えようと思ったっても意味がないんです
ある日 私はある人に なんであんた
あの人にあんな汚い言葉を使ったんですか？と言ったら
だってあいつは先に私にこんなこと言ったんだからと
だから本人が自分が相手を汚い言葉を使ったことが正しいと思っているんです
誰だってそんなもんなんですよ
子供だけじゃないんです
はい 次のタイトル 尊敬する人というタイトル
皆に尊敬する人物が一人二人いますね
時々子供たちにもいますね
いろんな自分が尊敬している人物が
その人の生き方を学んで
自分の人生を変えようとします
野球好きな子はもう自分の好みの選手がいて
その人のやり方から学びたくなる
そういうふうな世界でしょ
我々が生きている世界は
しかし 皆 俗世間の目的で俗世間の偉大なる人物を選ぶんです
私たちは偉大なる人物を選ぶ場合は
この野球選手とかね 歌手なら何々さんをモデルにしますとかね
そういうふうな人間を選ぶんですね
医者なら何々医者のように頑張らなくちゃとかね
そうやって俗世間の目的で俗世間の人間を選ぶんです
私たちが尊敬する 影響を受ける偉大なる人物も
貪瞋痴の支配下で生きていたのです
だから どんな野球選手のやり方を学んだとしても
その野球選手が貪瞋痴できているんだから
その野球選手から学んで一流になる子供も大したことはないんですよ
歴史のあるいろんな人物を皆さんは学ぶでしょう
学んで自分の人生に影響を与えるようにする
完全たる人格者 ですから
我々はそういうアインシュタインであろうが
完全たる人格者ではない
イエス様をモデルにしたっても
全然完全たる人格者ではないんですね
もたがい多い人生なんですね
インドにもいますけどね
まあどこかでだらしない
汚いところはあります
インド人がマハトマ・ガンディーをね
尊敬しますけど ガンディーの生涯読んでみると
まあなんだ この人かいという感じになるんです
人格はもうあんまり まあ我々よりはいいんだけど
我々一般人よりは立派かもしれませんだけど
もう完璧じゃないんですね
貪瞋痴に支配されているんだから
人格完成した貪瞋痴を打ち破った人を尊敬する人物として選ぶべきです
他の方法はないんです
小学者であるブッダがその人物です
ブッダと阿羅漢たちを尊敬する人物
影響を受ける人物として選ぶならば
それは正しい選択です
ここで我々はこの三聚争の心を変えようとしているんです
誰かの助けなければできないんです
これは 自分勝手にやっちゃうと
自分の仕事正しいんだからね
どうにもならんです それで人を選ぶんです
選ぶならば 完全たる人格者を選ばなくちゃいけない
それだったら ブッダでたった一人の人間になるんです
世の中 他誰もいません
それで幸福の扉が開きます
貪瞋痴が減らせば減らすほど幸福になるんです
希望で幸福になりません
希望は欲ですから不幸になるんです
希望 夢を抱くと逆効果になるんです
目的設定するのは構わないんですけど
目的設定して生きてます
が 希望欲望は捨てた方がいいんです
失敗します しかし 我々は目的を設定して貪瞋痴を抑える
そうすると うまく幸福の扉が開いてくれます
ブッダの功徳を念じること
これは不貪不瞋不痴のポジティブ感情で
思考を正しい思考に置き換える訓練です
ブッダの功徳を念じるとは
思考の置き換える訓練なんです
くだらないことを考えないで
自分が正しいと思うものを考えないで
ブッダの功徳について考えるんです
考えて念じるんです 頭いっぱいするんです
長く時間取るんです 長い時間
例えば 1時間ぐらいブッダの功徳を考える
1時間で貪瞋痴がないんです
それで無意識に影響入る
微妙に潜在煩悩にも影響入るんです
もう幸福になってます
もうとっくに幸福になっているんです
九徳 唱える 唱え始めた瞬間から心は清らかになります
だって私はパーリ語を知ってるんだから
いつだってちょっといろんなことで混乱しているときは
まあパーリ語でイティピソバガワナレハン
サンマサンブッドと自分に歌うんです
それで落ち着く 瞬間で
ヴィッチャーチャラナサンパンノ
ソガトーローカウィドゥ
アヌッタロープーリセダンマサーラティ
サッターデーヴァマヌッサナン
ブッダバガワーティ で
もう今も落ち着きました
まあ講演ずっとやって疲れていたんだけど
疲れがピッと消えちゃった
だからすごく力ですよ
それが 私にその力があるのは
もうパーリ語を知っているし
意味はちゃんと知っているんだからなんです
貪瞋痴が抑えられます
あらゆる悩み 妄想がなくなって落ち着きます
それは幸福の結果をもたらします
いたって簡単です 九徳は難しい
しかし 意図的にお釈迦様が九徳は難しいとしているんです
時々注釈 今日はあまり難しいんだから紹介しません
それだけでも講演 2つぐらい必要になるんです
で 注釈書ももう大変ですよ
注釈するのは わかっているかいないかっていう疑問まで私にも起こるぐらいです
なぜかというと たった一言葉
阿羅漢 釈尊っていうのは阿羅漢なんです
阿羅漢ってなんですか？とSTUDYしなくちゃあかんです
それで勉強しているでしょ
考えてるでしょ 汚れた思考じゃないでしょ
阿羅漢っていうのは煩悩がない状態
貪瞋痴がない状態 すべてに対する執着を捨てた状態
いわゆる資格完成した状態
人格完成した状態なんです
それって何ですか？と
勉強すると まあかなり頭で仕事をしているんです
それも唱える 呪文のように唱えることじゃないんです
本を開けて勉強する 本を開けて読む
延々と書いてますよ 注釈書では
阿羅漢の説明は ブッダの説明はすごい
長く長く これは読んで読んで
鵜呑みにしないで理解する
これでかなり頭のホームワークは起きているんです
それでどんどんどんどん影響が良い影響が入って
心の手術が自動的に起こるんです
だからこの九徳は阿羅漢
サンマーサンブッダ ヴィッチャーチャラナサンパンノ
皆さんは反響しているでしょ
スグトローカウィドゥ
例えばローカウィドゥっていうのは 5番目
世間解というふうに日本訳しますけど
世間を知っている 世間とは生命のこと
一切生命のことを知り尽くしているということは
ブッダが知らないものは何もないんです
お釈迦様は知らないものは何もないんです
生命とは何かというと
仏教が色受想行識と五蘊であると
それで私たちは色受想行五蘊を学ぶ
生命に至ってもこの 5つでしょう
だからお釈迦様がそれを知り尽くしたといえば
私にもそれ知り尽くすことできますねということになるんです
それでも心がきれいになっているんですよ
これアヌットロ  6番目
アヌットロプーリセダンマサーリプッタ
えっと 何でしたっけ？日本訳は
調教丈夫という日本訳ですね
いわゆるどんな人も調教することにはこの上のない能力を持っている
お釈迦様には育てられない人物は
生命はいません それって何ですか？と
やっぱりお釈迦様には潜在煩悩を読めるんです
だから不可能はなし そういうふうに我々はブッダの徳を学ぶんです
能力 徳といったって それで心がきれいになってきれいになっていく
自分の心が 意味は簡単ではありません
しかし 苦労して学ぶと真理に対して理解が深まります
九徳を一つ選んで理解して念じることもできます
大体テーラワーダ世界では一つ選ぶんですね
タイでは阿羅漢という単語だけ
選んで念じてるんですね
でもあれで 私はあんまり気に入らんだけど
阿羅漢 阿羅漢 阿羅漢と言ったってもね
あるいはプットー プットー
あれ ブッドーという言葉を念じますね
アチャンチャーのところではね
ブッドーと発音しないし
プットー プットーと言いますけど
プットーでの息子って意味ですけど
まあもうまあどうしようもない
あちらの訛りですから
そんなことを念じたっても
でも考えてください あの人
お坊さんたちが道場掃除するときでも
ブットー ブットー ブットーと言いながら掃除するんです
掃きを吹くと ブットー
ブットー ブットー 心清らかになるんです
他の思考入らないでしょ？ブッダしか入ってないんです
だから結構立派ですよ
ああいうお坊さんたちが
すごい立派な人格者なんです
まあスリランカでもまあやる人々は一つ選んで
それを唱えるんですね
人格向上へ 九徳が一つを唱え始めたら
ブッダが貪瞋痴を打ち破ったことを繰り返し思考に入ります
貪瞋痴は打ち破るべきです
貪瞋痴は敵です 悪魔ですという考え
気持ちがどんどん繰り返し
繰り返し繰り返し入るんです
それで心のシステムが変わっていくんです
貪瞋痴の衝動で現れる思考は一時的になくなります
念じ始めたら 不貪不瞋不痴という解毒剤が現れます
それで初めて心の中に解毒剤が生まれるんです
解毒剤が生まれたら 毒をもう緩和するというか
なくしてなくしていくんです
瞋恚の故意は不善から善行為に変わります
あまり無理をしなくても
私たちの言葉が正しい言葉になっているんです
だって思考が直ったんだから
我々の生き方が正しい生き方になっているんです
日常の考えがもう正しくなっているんです
OK です 失敗しないんです
それで 善から不善に入れ替えるんです
それが人生全体に影響を与えるので幸福になります
その時は思考次第 その時も今清らかな思考をしているんです
その訓練しているんです
慣れるまで それで思考次第で幸福になります
表面の思考が正しい思考のではなくとに変わります
欲望 汚れた感情は清らかな不貪不瞋不痴に変わります
思考は正しい思考になる
貪瞋痴は不貪不瞋不痴に変わります
それは裏面の汚れた煩悩に影響を与えて弱くします
解毒剤が入ります あの裏の心に
無意識にも 繊細煩悩が目覚めて刺激を与えても反応しないことができるようになります
それすごいことなんです
万が一 繊細煩悩が目覚めたらとんでもないことになるんです
これはなくなるんです
繊細煩悩が目覚めても
上は解毒剤が働いてますからね
上に来ないんです だから身を守れます
あの突然わけもわからないことをすることは
念仏する人にとってはあり得ません
起こりません やがて繊細煩悩も弱くなっていきます
苦のみが起こるようになっている人生は根本から変わります
人生っていうのは 苦が生きることは苦
苦によって生まれて 苦で生きていて
もう苦しみで苦しんで死ぬという
全部苦なんです ドゥッケローコパティット生命は苦しみに
置かれているんだと教えていますからね
ドゥッカンティッティティチェ
現れるのも苦 維持管理しているのも苦
なくなるのも苦であると
苦しかないんですね だからこの苦は思考を作っているんです
それで我々は思考が根本的に変えるんです
変えちゃうと苦がなくなるんです
そろそろ終了します ブッダの功徳だけですかね
この働きは そうではありません
仏法を学ぶこと 念じること
唱えること 経典とか それでもいいんです
パーリ語でわからなかったら
日本語で読んでみる 真剣に
心清らかになります 見事に何か不思議に人生は幸福になります
あれ 神秘何もないんです
例えば朝昼晩とか朝晩でもね
慈経を唱える パーリ語と日本語で
結構私が一部唱えたような感じで
自分の気持ちに訴えて唱えてみてください
1週間以内で何でもうまくいくようになるんです
全然不思議じゃないんです
神秘的じゃないんです
自分の思考が治るんです
心理学的なんです 聖者たちの人生を念じることもできます
あるいは阿羅漢たち サーリプッタ尊者
マハーカッサパ尊者 私も時々そういう尊者であって
聖者たちのことも考えたりもします
また 慈悲喜捨の瞑想 無常の瞑想
不浄の瞑想 死随観という瞑想
そういうものでも思考パターンが変わります
汚れた思考が正しい思考に変わります
同じ結果になります 功徳を念じることは
信仰を押し付けることではありません
ただ単にブッダしか人がいないだけの話です
ブッダを信じなさいという意味じゃないんです
他宗教のようにマインドコントロールすることでもありません
本当は洗脳洗脳なんですね
他宗教で神という概念で洗脳するんです
これはそうじゃなくて
勉強することだから 貪瞋痴を不貪不瞋不痴に入れ替える唯一方法ですよ
だから完全な科学的な方法ですよ
功徳 功徳を念じることは
科学というのは仏教 心理学
科学 心理学 心の構造はブッダしか発見していないし
ですから それでちゃんとした科学的なアプローチでお釈迦様は直るのを教えているんです
だからこの功徳はお釈迦様だけじゃないんですよ
過去のブッダたちにも功徳があったんだからね
どんなブッダも功徳なんです
だからこれ個人崇拝じゃないんです
はい まあそろそろ終わります
ブッダの代わりに神を念じたらどうなるのかと
意味がありません 効き目もありません
だってこういう妄想じゃないでしょ
神自体が妄想概念でしょ
しかし 欲 怒りなどの感情が弱くなるならば
それぐらいの結果があります
まあ結果ゼロってわけじゃないんです
智慧は出てあるわけですよ
神様にお祈りする方々も
いい性格の方々は結構いますよ
優しくて 人を助けてあげたりして
かなり立派な方々はいます
朝晩神に祈ったりしてね
だから彼らの貪瞋痴が
欲 怒りがいくらか減ってはいるんです
しかし 智慧は現れません
神は信仰している限りは智慧はあります
現れません それがもう盲信
迷信ですからね 苦しみを乗り越えることもできません
神を念じることでいい人間になれますけど
輪廻転生を脱することことはできません
神は人間が作った妄想概念のキャラですが
人格完成してないんです
問題は ヒンドゥー教の神々も人格完成していないのでだらしないんですよ
ギリシャ人の神々もそうでしょう
だらしないんです イエスではなくて
ジェホワ神も怒りの神
嫉妬の神と言ってるでしょうね
本人が だらしないんですね
だから偉そうに威張ってるんだけど
人格的にはもう当てにならない
それだったらお母さんを信仰してください
神よりは効き目があるんです
自分を褒め称えることを期待するキャラです
グローリートゥーザファーザーという言葉はどうしても必要ですね
神に栄光ありとかね バカじゃないかなと私は思いますけどね
偉大なる人にとっては
そんなことくだらん 我々虫けらみたいな人間がね
神の上に栄光ありと言ったってもね
どうでもいいことでしょうに
だから神を念じる場合は
この人格完成していないというところは大きなポイント
次のポイントは自殺しないことなんです
欲で作った妄想概念ですね
しかし 人間がある程度で優しくしなさい
愛しさい あれやこれやとか言ってますから
その分は貪瞋痴が抑えられます
人を愛することで貪瞋痴がいくらか減らせます
ですから その分幸せになります
だから宗教はもう全く無意味ではないんです
それなりに結果があるとは思います
九徳はそうじゃないんだよ
九徳の不思議な力 不思議というのは一般人では理解できないこと
説明しましたけどね 不思議な力を仏教心理学的な立場で解明しました
究極に不思議な力があります
この不思議な力がこういう力であると今説明しました
念じると私たちの人生は根本から改良します
遺伝子組み換えのような働きだと理解しておきましょう
幸福になりたいと希望すると
煩悩の衝動なので なのでではなくてね
なの 煩悩の衝動なので不幸になります
幸福になる方法は 幸福を忘れて究徳を唱えることです
幸福の概念を忘れちゃって
究徳を唱えて立派な人間になるんです
頭のいい それで幸福になります
確実に幸福になります
はい これで今日の講演は終了します
どうもありがとうございます
ウェーサーカ先生 ありがとうございました
ちょうど九時になりましたので
これで終了したいと思います
最後に皆さんで回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に大礼敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに廻向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビートゥ アジャントゥ サッブローゴー ナッサトー マテー パワッサンタラーヨー スケーディー ジャイコーバヴァ
バウトゥ サッブマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッブデーヴァター サッブブンダヌバーヴェーナ サッブダンマヌバーヴェーナ
サッブサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー サッティ パワントゥ テアーヴィラーダナシーリッサニンチャン ワッダー プジャイナ
チャッター ルーダンマー ワッダンティヤー イバンノー スカーン バラン
はい どうもありがとうございます
サーリプッタサーリプッタ